peu
oui
l'amour comme on dit
devant autant de points aimait la vie
quand on digère bien moi je dis j'ai un
bien j'aime à digérer en présence de ma
femme adorée et près d'une belle maman
respecter oui un beau prix est un pigeon
science un fidèle ami d'enfance se
servait d'un grand voyageur célibataire
qui nous a pas quittés de tout l'été ce
dont je remercie le moins cher jacques
une ravissante personnes habitant
l'auberge vient de temps à autre de
rappeler que si les bruins ont jailli
les blondes ne le sont pas moins et d'où
sortez vous vous moi je suis la bonne le
cdj est la bonne
et bien quand on sonne la bonne c'est
comme une chaîne quand on assiste elle
arrive quand il a pacifié
sadi a amorcé la porte d'entrée je me
suis trompé mais si je me sais pas
l'argenterie j'aurais pas les manoirs
soyons trop le dehors et peut-être akron
chez moi le dedans et votre saison
commencée tourner autour des toutes les
ip c'est un long mois somme fatigue
alors vous vous refuseriez bien dans mon
petit magasin de teinturerie pressing
rue lecourbe à paris vous ne verrez
jamais l'idée que dix rencontres que des
clients et encore pas toujours content
tandis qu'ici à mater dame
vous pouvez les remercier vos parents
car vous la connaîtrez jamais assez
votre chance d'être licencié en
philosophie mais tu ne dis rien à fiche
à quoi penses tu dis tiens vraiment à le
savoir
ah oui on dit papy des appâts pudeur
mais c'est moi je le disais à six mois
je suis prête à tout montrer pour tout
comprendre moselle limiter la réserve
des dieux qui dans toutes les religions
et
prophète ne se sont exhibés merci
qu'avec une grande discrétion
alors je les pose tard d'albert mais je
pensais à la mort mais qu'ils mourront
c'est dû à la tienne albert à ta mort
mais c'est affreux
maintenant qu'ils payent tige je suis
d'un optimisme inébranlable j'ai une
santé de fer
c'est par esprit de contraste quel
contraste
ah ouais je vous le demande quel contre
maga chez volvo contraste c'est vrai ça
il pourrait nous porter malades qui avec
ses contrastes certain johnny comme tu
es sans enfant tu pourrais encore
choisir un hattrick distingue notre cher
à l'état mais ce qu'on pas superstitieux
jerry tutu ponctionne maintenant avec de
quelle façon un très simplement atteint
ferait mal au pape a fait mouche en jce
conversation mois comme albert j'aime
les chansons la shdm guy laliberté le
pain blanc les petits oiseaux la justice
comme des princes la justice elle
disparaît la liberté avec le pain blanc
la justice qu'elle ait justice à moi
pour me regarder dans la vie j'ai besoin
de boussole la gégène coussin j'ai
besoin de morale et méfiez vous des
mousseux c'est elle est déjà mené en
prison
et alors et alors chacun à sa manière de
gagner sa vie à toi tu vends des autos
tu sais pourtant longtemps certaines
voitures seront responsables d'accidents
est ce que cette approche les blessés et
les morts dont tu est la cause directe
alors parce que jouent les auto show le
nécessaire dans un sens parfaitement
vaille et moi une famille seraient pas
penser à ça et votre boussole qu'elle
est belle l'amitié par dessus tout
l'amitié a toujours l'amitié rien que la
victime car l'amitié même sens moral
c'est du tout droit devant soi à 6,00 me
albert pour une femme c'est même un peu
court amitié pour une femme le mot-clé
auquel on peut accrocher toute sa vie je
n'en vois qu'un pureté avant tout la
pureté pour issam pas vous voyez moi il
n'y pas de plus aurait pas dit ça si
gérez vous
mais à n'importe quel prix mon ami
l'honnêteté à n'importe quel prix tu as
raison ma fille mais sans drame car on a
déjà bien assez d'embêtements avec la
vieillesse et les rhumatismes devenir
rester ou redevenir une femme honnête à
n'importe quel prix et vous mais c'est
jacques
comment vivez vous moi non sur la pointe
des pieds
faut être toujours prêt à [ __ ] le camp
et qui sont épris moins que votre mari
et des préoccupations supérieur c'est
indéniable ah mais ça n'empêche pas
d'être heureux mais comment peut-on être
heureux dont on se demande le jour et la
nuit c'est une faisant sur la terre ne
suggère que nous faisons sur la terre
répond lotois même pas parce que nous
faisons sur la terre est évident on y
vit voyons on y verse mademoiselle par
loisel madame on divorce n'est pas
encore prononcée oui on n'arrive pas en
tête ça aussi c'est incompréhensible car
il me connaît ne connaîtront jamais l'ex
homme comme c'est vrai à six mois si je
souhaitais vous dire laisse pas l'heure
du bruit johnny va allonger va venir ici
je méprisais les joueurs de cartes si
vous les entendez dans les petits cafés
de vaugirard tapant du poing sur les
tapis des tableaux narcy il est vrai
qu'ils étaient lesquels en vacances
peut-être versant social géré mais de
bien des mystères entourent alors tu
fais peur pas alors l'un il soyez calme
par pitié de la pitié je ne leur ai pour
personne pas même pour moi
comme je suis heureuse objets et tu vois
les mystères de la vie et de la mort
pascal gauci monsieur roger
à vrai dire je suis un chat décourager
plus plus je réfléchis plus je m'endors
j'ai vu des envois ira c'est un
professeur retraité mon ami retraités et
délicatesse
ah c'est pas un homme lit par les jeunes
gens c'est grossier ça se voit tout
permis si vous ne comprenez rien plus
exactement je comprends tout mais à ma
manière qui n'est pas la manière des
autres sans doute pas je ne comprends
rien paraît-il à la manière de ceux qui
ne comprennent rien n'est ce pas mon
genre j'ai tu m'as dit dimanche parce
que nous nous rencontrons dimanche après
midi à monter pressing ou gêne
arrière-boutique meublé moderne se
souvient tu m'as dit pour chaque
question vous savez les questions qui
donne du vague à l'âme et des angoisses
even ya des réponses différentes et même
contradictoires que l'on peut choisir à
des niveaux variés et suivant son
tempérament
selon que tu es primaires secondaires ou
supérieures machine prix vert
mais c'est une bonne élève c'est un
pathogène
bon vous m'excusez je vais les jouer au
croquet oui d'un sport tendre qui me
rappelle les espoirs d'un enfant avec la
fille clochette sous l'arceau 12 juin
devrait y rester prénom georges et et
battante à peine ma petite fille tuée
que singer je ne tiens pas bien excuse
pas mon suivi mais tu le sais les
conversations d'idées ça n'existe pas
non mais a buté l'auberge du village
vous en êtes prié et m en avait tant
parlé de ces petites auberges ou tuer
mais parfois te réfugier seul pour
pincer au mystère du monde tu m'as
reconnu sur la route
c'était toi je t'ai pas un seul nom de
converser avec un monsieur oui c'était
mon gendre h et y compris tu m'expliquer
déjà tout deviné pas d'amis n'est pas
idiot simon joindra compte et wav aiff
l'homme s'était pas qu'avec sa licence
de philosophie et c'est pas des
histoires comme la nôtre exige pour une
fille à perth et tempêtes mai et
dimanche tu m'as dit rac en jeu les
papiers la ta phrase était probablement
vrai un dimanche après midi dans son
arrière boutique moins fort au sein de
ma famille bah ça ça ne gêne pas de
déjeuner avec ma femme très bouleversée
tu sais tu étais ma grande déception si
fréquenter des hommes intelligents et
stagne alors tout à coup voilà un petit
a aimés pendant 30 ans et dont
aujourd'hui l'envi touche à sa fin l'ong
qui va nous prendre et aussi j'ai envie
de l'embrasser lui manquerait plus que
ça comment toi qui met rien qu'au milieu
d'une tempête
parmi les vagues de l'océan une plume
d'oiseau a fait preuve que la terre
parmi les étoiles de la voie lactée
je m'en souviens c'était le soin de
notre premier jour c'est même à cause de
ça que je peux faire ce que tu appelait
le jardin de mon corps car c'est drôle
un temps j'étais bientôt tout début de
ma vie ce qui m'énervait c'était les
cheveux frisés
aujourd'hui c'est sauter france les
vagues des sièges qui m'affole bon
facile à bonn
son comportement est bien tolérée et
dégringolent des étoiles pour tera se
faire dans ces mesquineries geronnez le
trouble devant le silence éternel des
espaces infinis ne justifie pas toujours
certains manquements et une élémentaire
délicatesse délicatesse qui était pour
moi que vous causez vous perdez votre
temps un support dedicate faire avec
vous elle peut y aller ça m'énerve pas
du tout bon a donc si c'est avec
monsieur chatel à rien je suis obligé
d'en fermer les yeux mais avec monsieur
genre déjà l'an comme je l'avais
remarqué avec la route qui ça mais c'est
aussi fac aujourd'hui pourtant elle gère
l j'appelle requis lequel routine
la rouquine de monsieur georges qui
j'appelle quand il l'embrassait c'était
rigolo outils j'appelle cheikh bâ
journée vous interrogez les domestiques
tennistique de neige dit qu on est bien
tous à tour de rôle le domestique de
quelqu'un d'autre non alors la rouquine
c'était une grande fille populaire que
vous mais le japon n'avait le droit
d'habiter l'auberge non non être qu'on
paie et quand les fourmis du grimp est
le nom des gens pendant qu'elle s'y est
elle est bien [ __ ] et encore j'avais tout
le temps et vous qu'en pied avec m
non non non mais après déjeuner monsieur
georges les cieux étaient avec elle
ma bonne petite sieste qu'elle dise à
l'oeuvre andrew keen est tombé du ciel
c'est tous les deux bien le recommencer
à japper je suis
j'attends les aventures et laissez moi
vous dire encore que la grande rockin a
été moins joli que la première we7 de
l'année où j'ai accepté de venir servir
ici alors celle là on aurait dit une
vraie dame madame joséphine fait des
valises mais quelle valises les vôtres
sont à l'auberge ripplecove c'est une
m'a foutu ses valises sont à l'auberge
les syndiqués brasse des jurés ait été
la première
ah bon c'est pas vrai j'ai jamais jurer
qu'il était la première maintenant jetés
jury que serait la dernière faille avec
la première à lui ça ne rencontre est
capable au tas dégoûtant il est bien
sont aussi dégoûtant plus le lien avec
la jeunesse en noir aujourd'hui les
réseaux mais le bonheur et d'une
construction de larmes qui pour le
construire prend n'importe quel matériau
que tu possèdes avec ton algérienne que
tu vas me reconstruire mon bonheur d'un
ami de la maison célibataires en plus
alors si comprends pas c'est qui veut
pas mais croyant comme tous les grands
hommes d'affaires vous êtes certainement
un homme discret voilà je vous reconduis
à l'auberge maintenant je vais vous
cherchez à vous demande à la table de
bridge
alors je vous laisse mais c'est chaud
j'y vais
[Applaudissements]
chers amis je suis certain vous avez
déjà oublié cette rencontre jacques
jacques répond moi à tes yeux suis-je
une femme coupable mais encore une fois
non mais sans oublier que dans notre
côté à notre époque tout le monde est
coupable et avant tout en premier lieu
les juges
je chanterai de formule pour top 10 j'ai
à répondre impérieux suisse une femme
kurde tué une femme qui me plaît et ça
me suffit
et la bassée d'albert ne trouble pas
rassure-toi pas lu tout ça je peux te le
jurer quand tu es prenne mon mari que tu
le regardes mais je suis pas jaloux et
bien moi les remords m'étouffe et ses
remords ne conduise dans un drame j'ai
peur jacques touche même à l écran mais
je te l'aï déjà dit mais ce que tu peux
pas rester une seule minute sans ta
cervelle fonctionne et que ça tombe bex
de penser à ton arrivée pense à moi rien
câbles mais tu ne comptes pas quoi lalor
west brom je ne peux plus vivre ainsi
avec tous mes records sous le regard
calme de mon mari tu écoutes sur corps
en france pour dix jours
tu vas pas me laisser en paix nous
pendant ces dix derniers jours jacques
essaie de me comprendre
je ne peux plus supporter les regards si
doux d'albert le l'on regarde de mon
pauvre albert lourdes quoi il ne sait
rien ne se doute de rien voilà ce que je
ne peux pas supporter sa confiance
toutefois redonné une pure de solitude
dans une ville d'eau agréable pour
détendre tenait rebond jeudi conduire et
non et je ne vois hélas qu'une solution
est là quelle est ma décision est prise
tu peux m'en faire part où est mon crime
et au crime parce que tu me plais aux
suisses coupables
je sais pas mais quand tu viens dans mon
lit tu ne comprends rien au problème des
morales mon amour je suis coupable dans
la conscience d'albert s'il a la
conscience tranquille d'un mari normal
qui nous sied mais moi je sais mais sa
conscience je la vois toutes prêtes à
bondir sur moi pour me juger hors ma
décision est prise je te le répète et je
les prises dans le désespoir ô and fire
n'ai pas peur je m'en veux gravir
jour l'idée que c'est tromper albert
meet a tall ra mais bon ça autre chose
dans l'oubli et mon péché c'est à dire
ma ronde c'est à dire mon remords je ne
peux pas le supporter ce rebond doit 10
par rapport à 6tu retrouve ainsi la
tranquillité
moi je veux bien alors expliquez moi
comment tu le fasses ton remords hélas
je ne vois qu'une solution est facile
albert d'effacer albert puisque albert
émon remords vivant et que je veux tu es
mon remords quand albert ne vivra et ils
aiment chanter de faire les santé de fer
on peut en venir à bout c'est qu'un
détail d'exécution d'exécution le moyen
d'agir autrement
alors ta petite cervelle agitée à rêver
d'axa steen et albert un assassinat
c'est la suppression d'armor la
suppression d'hormones pas que ces
intellectuels ça on en avait parlé gens
n'avaient jamais rencontré mais ça
valait le déplacement alors dans la
prison après qu'un crime tu te sentirais
innocente mais sur quatre prisons par le
tube qui te parle de crime
j'ai seulement imaginer un accident à
l'accident organisé bien tu plaisantes
un accident très bien organisée non non
écoute moi calmement à cause de mes
affaires à tanger et de mon goût de
passer inaperçu il est absolument
impossible que j'accepte d'être mêlé
même de très loin à une affaire
criminelle est une pense qu'à toi quand
je t'explique mon désir éperdu de
retrouver ma pureté morale mais moi qui
ne ment pas que jamais dans les ménages
parfaitement uni pour éviter toutes les
complications mais j'évite dans le mille
mais une femme marie madeleine métier d'
insensée et albert est un chic type
il c'est ton mari et tulle m
ah oui tu aimes comme une femme mariée
mais tulle m
s'il n'était pas mon mari et si je ne
l'aimé pas je n'aurai pas à le faire
mourir demain que c'est pour demain
l'exécution avant midi avant midi les
jetons l'empêcherait ça fait d'abord
penser à te demander de tirer le coup de
feu mais comme après l'accident
joséphine racontera aux gendarmes que je
vais te retrouver dans ton lit des coûts
s'est endormi albert avec duvet ronaldo
aurait été tout de suite soupçonné et
pour le crime tu augmentes à dos 2-2 qui
emploie des mots dont on ignore le sens
problème est posé qui ne comporte qu'une
solution et smartphones tu va opérer toi
même nom dans le plan prévu
je n'aurais à pleurer d'ailleurs mon
chagrin sera très sincère a tué
découvrir un ennemi intime d'albert qui
le détestent et qui désirent sa main tu
n'es pas doué pas du tout l ennemi
d'albert pour le toit mais ce serait
absurde
les policiers sursis compassionnel qui
serait tout de suite arrêté non j'ai
organisé un accident avec de vrais
personnages l'accident entouré de ses
meilleures amies naturellement sauf toi
qui serait tout de suite soupçonné à
cause de joséphine qui ne sera pas même
témoin de l'accident est l'un d'eux
tuera comme ça donne à son vieux
camarade d'enfance pour te faire plaisir
on va faire plus non il me prend très
cher parce que lui aussi aura beaucoup
de chagrin
tous les louis d'or qu'albert voulais te
confier pour les cacher à tanger il les
exige alors je les lui donne il est
difficile de discuter un tel contrat les
tarifs sont peu connus - moitié parvenu
à m'indigner pourquoi tout le monde va
être si content l'ami d'albert et tous
de gros lot inespéré toi qui m'aura tout
à toi moi qui n'aurait plus honte devant
mon mari mais ton mari il sera content
lui aussi bien sûr puisqu'il sera mort
et sans souffrance
oui je me suis arrêté à 1 prenant c'est
moi je veux rien et nous dialoguons
alors tu l'apprendra par les journaux
mon amour dans la chronique des faits
divers car j'ai choisi un vieux truc
oublié et comme les policiers n'ont
aucune culture ils ne connaissent plus
un accident de chasse voilà pourquoi je
t'ai demandé de ne pas aller demain
matin à la chasse comme c'était pas pour
venir me dire bonjour dans la chaude
pour que les policiers me d'élise dans
ton lit pas qu'ils ramèneront ici le
corps du pauvre albert sur les civières
quelle horreur parce que je raisonne
comme un général à la veille d'une
bataille quand ils s'informent du
pourcentage des parts possible mais une
bataille si la libre le général c'est
pour le bien de son pays et il la livre
basque et les général et les général
parce qu'il aime ce métier là je le sais
j'ai une amie de 100 vonn qui était la
maîtresse d'un général et va ce qu'il
est mais elle me l'a répété c'est l
angoisse durant la bataille
moi qui ne suis pas général ce n'est pas
par dix ces mêmes sans joie mon amour
que demain je fais tirer le canot le
crime parfait n'existe pas
je t'ai vu quelque part donc quelque
chose cloche sera j'ai déjà rédigé -
même le fait divers comme un journaliste
est pas d'armes compte-rendu ya le club
albert par la loeb avec roger rangée de
dénoncera pour se faire arrêter
voici tout de même d'un rocher qui
devait lui il a besoin d'argent comme
moi j'ai besoin de ma tranquillité
morale son vieux camarade d'enfance qui
donne à l'amitié dans la vie un prix à
bly à très grand prix voilà pourquoi les
modèles de 5000 louis après avance la
menthe et c'est cher mais mieux vaut
considérer les choses avec simplicité
oui oui ben moi je pars tout de suite
pour l'afrique et je reviendrai en
france plus tard quand on parlera
d'autre chose en gros ou sur la pointe
des pilotes il partira pas et plus tard
quand j'aurai reconstruit ma fierté tube
épousera car je veux redevenir une femme
n'est qui n'aura connu dans sa vie que
deux hommes et la halle après l'autre
avec au moment de la rencontre une
franche un peu hésitant à parce que tu
t'imagines que je me suis maintenu
jusqu'à l'âge de 40 ans célibataire pour
être aux hans hess pas mon amour tu es à
mes ordres
j'ai un revolver tu n'aurais pas bouclé
ses valises que j'aurais déjà tué albert
moi-même et avoué aux policiers que
j'étais envoûté par toi que c'était une
femme tranquille vivent près de son mari
bien aimé ce qui est vrai je révèlerai
ensuite qu'elle a dit vers minuit tu vas
prise de force ce qui est encore vrai et
que j'ai été absolument stupéfaite du
résultat ce qui est toujours vrai si
vrai que j'étais demandé de recommencer
et le résultat stupéfiant se renouvelant
chaque fois j'ai continué tout cela
n'est-il pas la vérité mon amour alors
j'ajouterai que tu m'a poussé au crime
ce qui deviendra vrai si empêchant rejet
de remplir son contrat qui m'oblige à
opérer moi même ce pauvre albert vers le
chi le destin d'albert serait le même et
ont décidé à toi sera bouleversée et tu
auras tout les embêtements alors que je
te demande de faire de mal à grasse
matinée
en attendant tranquillement dans son lit
le retour de la chasse ni bon sang de
bonsoir vous paraissait pourtant
aménagées ou bien unis confortable sans
histoire oui avant son arrivée quand je
n'avais pas de remords tt agréable
ton mari sympathique bonbons bridgeurs
bon on mangeait mal chez toi mais je
vous emmener au restaurant
les couples et les vacances allaient
finir dans dix jours je partais content
j'aime trop albert pour supporter l'idée
qu'ils puissent apprendre ma trahison
avait alors ne vous éloignez pas nous
avons encore des détails à régler pour
demain matin oui aux bernois mesure le
regard d'un homme ne m'a jamais effrayé
et je vais vous regarder dans les yeux
et vous dire toute ma pensée je suis
complètement déconcertée moi aussi
monsieur jacques est au courant de notre
avancement son ami n'êtes vous pas aussi
le sien mais laissez moi vous dire
monsieur que je n'aurais jamais accepté
l'idée de tuer mon ami mais vous allez
accepter monsieur l'idée de se
déshonorer
mais de nos jours monsieur le déshonneur
le déshonneur plus personne et si des
zones orillia albert l'ignorent mais il
ignorera aussi sa mort elle sera suivie
trois j'aime la premier né ce projet et
tous les deux je ne veux pas pu vous et
verviers
mon petit sac n'oubliez pas mes paroles
si vous vous éloignez de cette maison
ce sont les gendarmes qui vous
ramèneront et albert n'aurait même pas
la joie d'une dernière partie de chasse
monsieur j'ai déjà tout oublié et je
vous prie vous souvenir que je ne suis
au courant de rien
mais moi aussi monsieur j'ai déjà tout
oublié 105 voyez vous je pourrais
tolérée chez mon ami la présence de
l'amant de sa femme
c'est un comble oui mais laissez moi
vous dire monsieur que je me sens moins
coupable à la place qu'à la longue dit
monsieur seraient là ma place comme vous
dites si vous ne vous étiez parmi
d'abord à la vôtre si vous entrez dans
la chaîne des responsabilités nous en
avons pour l'éternité
en bref le vrai coupable au début de la
chaîne c'est albert si elle perd ne
m'avait pas épousé jacques ne leur est
pas trompé et rochelle ne seraient pas
contraints demain alors d'aller à la
chasse
une chasse à l'homme pensé d'abord vous
aller chasser la femme monsieur non j'ai
pas de repousser et pense pour te calmer
à notre avenir à tous les deux enfin
réunis parce que vous voulez poudre et
après il le faut bien
je vais être une femme honnête à
n'importe quel prix eh bien monsieur
vous êtes plus courageux que je ne le
pensais
car vous ne pourrez pas ignorer que la
situation de marine notre ami n'est pas
une situation exempte de dangers ou sans
relation je n'ai pas à redouter la
sollicitude monsieur d'un camarade
d'enfance qui placent l'amitié au dessus
de tout
vous savez un type marie madeleine j'ai
craqué devant ce vilain coco mais albert
livre a une fois de plus albert ados
raison vous ne ferez jamais servi en
affaires vous êtes toujours l'homme des
chèques sans provision je vous jure que
c'est pas commun tout au moins à
l'imagination de tirer dans le dos d'un
ami pascal verrai mon ami mais hier
quand je vous ai demandé de me rendre ce
service vous savez tout tout de suite
accepté et cette nuit je me suis les
analyser pour comprendre comment on
avait pu accepter
j'aime bien que mes gestes soient
transparents quand je regarde bien ce
que j'ai accepté hier ce n'est pas de
tuer le maire ce sont vingt cinq mille
louis vous allez être obligé nouvelle et
rend alors non et si je vous devez
jacques pour seulement 4000
soyez sérieux roger tu es jacques
n'effacerait pas mon crime c'est devant
albert que je ne parviens pas à vivre
sans remords 5000 louis de nos jours
pour un mort c'est bien payé je me
reconnais c'est un prix deux de grands
médecins cela bride chirurgien
réfléchissez une seconde régime et de
penser à toutes ces images grouillante
de meurtre penser à tous les avions à
toutes les autos sur les routes dans les
airs tous les hôpitaux à tous les
abattoirs à tous les filets de pêcheurs
et regardant ces milliards d'insectes
d'oiseaux de reptiles de vaches de
mouches qui meurent par millions à
chaque seconde à tous les petits enfants
ou vieillards il à toutes les banques de
toutes les guerres alors dans ce tohu
bohu vue de là haut
croyez vous que la mort d'albert ne
passera pas inaperçu je deviens ont
peut-être mais moi je suis en bas réduit
alors votre bel enthousiasme d'hier
chaque année 5000 oui bien sûr j'avais
été aussi enthousiasmés par le côté
métaphysique de l'aventuré ce parti
quand on donne la vie on ne connaît
jamais prévenu et sur le moment on pense
souvent à autre chose et on ne sait
jamais on va tout de suite si
l'expérience a réussi et comme la vie et
la mort sont les deux faces d'un même
problème
je me disais qu'en se revend donné la
mort au moment où on l'attendait enfin
bref george buffet des idées vous
m'abandonner sans secours dans l'horreur
que j'ai moi même je suis prêt à tenter
ma grande expérience métaphysique mais
sur jacques d'amore j'accepterai plus
d'aller avec vous à la chasse il n'est
pas intelligente mais tout de même vous
alors la maîtresse cet homme qui n'est
pas cultivé ça c'est déconcertant
maîtresses appelées aussi d'équateur dès
que je les ai été moi même
or c'est à fait dans utilise obligé
tenir compte maintenant je suis plus du
tout déconcerté écouté que je peux pas
m'en je suis pas dormi de la nuit
demain quand ce sera terminé vous
dormirez comme un enfant moi je vous
remercie de vos paroles d'encouragement
même était petit de quoi avez vous pas
de la pensée de tuer un homme qui est
mon ami et de devenir pour toujours
l'homme qui aura tué son amie alors vous
seriez chirurgien vous ne seriez pas
opérer albert s'il était chirurgien jeu
sera pas obligé de rater l'opération
mais je ne veux pas que demain vous
ratiez l'opération est d'ailleurs à bout
portant
il n'est pas possible que vous ratiez
albert j'y reviens si je le paierai ce
serait pour son bien et demain quand
vous opérez albert de mon péché ce sera
pas pour son bien il est heureux vous
savez albert ne pourra jamais être plus
heureux qu'il est aujourd'hui
mais sylvie encore demain quel sera son
avenir il apprendra que jacques le
trompe que vous avez accepté de le tuer
en eau non moi je ne veux pas qu'elle
vient plus à prendre une telle horreur
et ne l'oublié pas il est la richesse
mais il peut devenir chômeur ce sera la
vieillesse les rhumatismes la sciatique
la calvitie total il mènera même plus
votre hésitation et criminel mais
comprenez que je manque d'habitude on
quand vous signer des chèques sans
provision qui vous dit qu'il ne ruine
pas des familles entières basculant des
vieillards dans le suicide et vous
hésiteriez devant une opération
bienfaisante payer en or je n'avais
jamais vu ça mille louis assemblé en un
seul tu as le spectacle en est
bouleversant mais derrière tous ces
louis d'or surgit le cadavre d'albert
vous qui avez le sens du néant de la
finitude de la condition humaine
expliquez-moi la nécessité de la
présence vivante sur la terre d'albert
mais s'il pouvait comprendre vos
problèmes et ils vous diraient lui-même
tegam montpetit viotti alors justement
ce qui me gêne c'est tiré dans le dos se
donnent tous les ans prévenir et dieu
est ce qu il nous prévient date il nous
dira c'est juste et ce compte et vous
offrir en prime après l'enterrement
un autre paquet de 5000 oui ça mais les
5000 10000
vous auriez doublé c'était un accident
très bien payé aucune compagnie
d'assurance n'homologue réapparaît
tarifs pensée 10000 oui pour un cadavre
à ce prix là passe à payer même
l'amérique ne pourrait faire la guerre
alors voilà on coupe la poire en deux je
renonce au deuxième paquet je garde le
premier est tous les deux on passe à
autre chose
je vous propose de changer cet or en
quelques grains de plomb de la chimie à
l'envers voilà qui devrait exciter à
l'esprit comme le vôtre mais tu dois en
bourse alors je ne dirai rien je pense
réellement que votre manque de parole
vous aura privé des 5000 oui déjà versé
et des 5000 autres louis que je vais
déposer à l'instant dans votre chambre
mais que vous me rendrai demain matin 6
comment voulez vous qu'un homme ruiné
qui aiment le confort mais il ne pense
pas que la destinée humaine est un sens
puissent résister à une telle tentation
au rocher il avait été heureux autres
aujourd'hui vous ne seriez pas content
d'être mort avant tout vos ébats c'est
le cas d'albert fait leur palais mon
hésitation me donne le vertige mais je
ne peux pas mère est en train de me
perdre si petite contrée qu'elle a
demandée ne saura jamais pourquoi on
s'en fout mon petit moulin on s'en fout
de toi allemand hapag est perçu comme
toi j'ai bossé ne pas perdre et pourtant
qu'il est aujourd'hui la valeur de
l'argent c'est bien simple parfois je me
demande à quoi bon travailler
à quoi bon vivre ben mon vieux rangez
vous attendez rocher a pas envie de toi
un homme heureux
allons allons je serais heureux avec six
petites contrées enfin c'est amer et n'a
pas fait l'impasse sur l'étape de coeur
il se fera plus mais ben tu verras tu
verras tu es assez riche en une erreur
tu veux sont plus tremblant cas - new
look qui minent aujourd'hui tu te fais
des soucis pour les gagner quand tu des
dépenses d'un mauvais genre une fois
dépenser sur les impôts qui rapplique
monsieur tu les paies pas des impôts
c'est vrai que tu vaux pour savoir ce
que j'aurais à payer si je vais payer
ses découragements est tellement
important casse-croûte que veux tu que
je te prête pas à willer demain s'il
pleut j'irai pas la chasse - oui
fragonard y avait fait humide en ce
moment j'ai alors sensibles n'ont pas tu
lui prêtera de mai pull-over
avec une bonne bouteille de muscadet je
te donnerai du pâté de tête et mon foie
thiam a à ce point là le pâté de tête
toit avec une omelette au lard ben
diogoye et 6 mai démangeaisons gros
prennent elles ne reprendront pas plus
jamais je te prends mais tu ne te
grattes a vaincu jamais non il va de
l'homme c'est vrai quand on pense aux
gens qu'on a aimé tant de remords vous
étouffe de ne pas leur avoir fait
plaisir quelquefois dans les plus
petites choses
albert tu aura même droit à un verre de
rhum vas-y que légitime à petit feu
c'est moi qui joue sur la fin de mes
jours pourrait plus jamais mangé de
pâtes et peut-être ni de métaux rares
pourquoi quelle mauvaise de la vie est
absurde bon autant de désespoir bien
alors un jour par hasard pour rencontrer
un homme désespéré lui aussi parce qu'il
s'est lui aussi que la vie est absurde
parfait mais vous aimez cet homme parce
qu'ils pensent comme vous qu'il n'ya
rien à attendre de la vie sur la terre
mais comme vous l'aimez
c'est le bonheur alors la vie n'est plus
absurde mais si la vie n'est plus
absurde
comment pouvez vous aimez aller pour
cette seule raison qu'ils jugent la vie
absurde alors vous n'aimez plus mais si
vous n'aimez plus parce que la vie n'est
plus absurde
ce manga mourante à nouveau votre vie
naturellement sentir elle pense et à
tourbillon oui mais c'est votre affaire
qu'ils m'expliquent qu'ils ont car on
garde quand la vie est absurde car
précisément joue au cas cette absurde
donc aux habitudes entortillé mais je
prends vraiment mais c'est peut-être
grave allait conduire à l'aim verton
plérin et eddy à table est ce que je
pense de ces annonces et la chute et du
bois trop élevé non mais tout compte
fait je ne veux pas le savoir et prends
ma place
lorsque toi tu préfère ignorer les
malheurs petits et grands bien sûr
pourquoi guerre rejet des pc vous madame
j'avais des angoisses des nausées des
ennuis et d enlever sérieux
catastrophique comme tout le monde quoi
lesquels les soucis de tous les grands
chefs d'entreprise peut-être dire le
souci de placer son argent
ouais t'as on aperçoit lula qui
rapplique an dernier
d'abord c'est pas de l'argent c'est de
l'or l'or on s'en fait une montagne non
feinte petit à l'étuvée or lors un jour
foutraque ans comme le reste tu crois
alors vous serez pas la peine
oui soit réaliste tu réalises puisque
l'époque et scientifique de nos jours
lors qu'est ce que c'est une collection
l'atome
ils nous ont les atomes sont prêts
isoler ceux qui sourient sont
individuelles est ce pas là comme des
petits clowns à tort et à travers mais
les craintes à mon petit vieux si on
fait aussi de petites lunes individuel
qui se baladent leurs espoirs satellite
et sont les mêmes qui entend l'identité
cette petite balade dans les petites
filles devaient lui dans les ctom un
accord ni fausse en dessous oui là ton
genre découvrent des astuces pour
fabriquer de l'or avec des petits cubes
de sable on lui décerne un prix nobel
oui nous on or tout pour être leur
vendre au prix du caillou blanc sera
transformé en poussière alors mon vieil
albert imagine un type qui te dirait
votre or un jeu vous le savez ne vaudra
pas le salaire d'un même un mois pour le
jeter en poussière à la poubelle en
poussière qui sera par la poussière de
renom mais la réponse hier la salle
poussière la poussière à ben ali et qui
rentrent pas tout
les fenêtres fermées et bien aujourd'hui
avec cette poussière là vous pouvez
sauver la vie d'un homme tu gères albert
que répondrait tu as un type l'a1 et il
tournait autour du pur pour me rappeler
le temps de travail est donc passé c'est
très grave
elle a toute ta vie de la sont francs de
moins dans ta poche ce qui est plus
grave que ça en france c'est grave
combien ces gras pour voir pour 10000
louis
deux millions c'est fou la vie d'un
homme et d'un homme 10000 oui il paraît
que c'est le prix je te jure que demain
un homme qui doit mourir demain sera
encore vivant sur la terre demain si tu
me donnes c'est d'emile louis odile
abonde chantage au suicide
or c'est bien ou mieux vaut ce prix là
je n'aime pas aujourd'hui mais louis
ainsi tu aurais à choisir entre la
poussière de 10000 louis et ma vie si tu
possédais elle et les 10000 oui quand tu
rêves
voilà tu me comprendrait donc tu
acceptes l'idée de ma mort contre à
10000 l'eau est d'abord qui perd est
avide emile louis et coach thème trop je
vais dire une réduction qu'elle me donne
seulement 5000 louis et aura pas de mort
demain tout à la folie des grandeurs pas
plus 5 10 il prend plus ça que 10 mai eu
une vie d'homme quand même nous sommes
tous portaient trice que la possession
de ça mais louis ça vous distingue des
autres c'est quelque chose toi
la situation est donc clair entre l'avis
d'un ami et 5000 louis voudrais-tu en
faire des saints mais louis tourret
rembourser une dette mais tu sais bien
que tu n'es jamais rembourser nos dettes
et avis mais c'est pour sauver de la
mort un ami on dit roger sur trois plus
facilement notre ami que ça me louer
mais imagine que ce soit ton meilleur
ami
et puis m comme tu t'aime toi même bien
rang s'il fallait penser la vie des
autres cantons à gagner du fric on
n'arriverait jamais à le garder leur
fais toi une raison la vie d'un homme
c'est fini aussi en poussière donne moi
ta poussière d'or et je te donne la
poussière d'hommes non non je
préfèrerais creuser et ben tu te rends
pas
non c'est du sa vraie non je refuse je
refuse parce que ce serait immoral
alors bon là autre chose toi aussi tu
vas être moral écoute si aujourd'hui la
possession de l'argent la seule vertu
qu'ils soient prend complètement
déconsidéré
c'est précisément ceux qui ont de
l'argent ont gagné alors le distribue à
ceux qui sont restés sur le bord de la
route
mais ce serait de considérer le travail
se fait mais tu es mon ami pour ce tarif
là pense mon petit vieux qui te reverrai
plus puisque tu le prends sur ce ton là
mon cher aux côtés de fred tu sais en
danger est-ce que tu donnerais ça mais
louis un chirurgien pour te sauver je ne
chantais de fer est un type bien
réitérer la bourse au mérite et c'est
vrai je suis dans ce blog est il un
fusil bon je reste quand même plusieurs
fois plus lors d'un débat dans un sens
j'ai mieux ça vient pourquoi comme le
bonduois sa musique lui qui s'est tous
dit alors si c'est tout il devrait
parler un peu plus grands comptes
si nous donner les cours de la bourse
aujourd'hui les cours de la bourse du
mois prochain
alors là oui je les prendrais tout de
suite des cellules louis et vos petits
vieux que quand je te regarde le chagrin
monsieur la gauche pourquoi je tenais
mulot tu te rappelles que nous
disputions déjà pour le partage du
nouveau oui je t'aimerai toujours les
miennes oui oui oui et a toujours eu
beaucoup et c'est pour ça c'est pourquoi
je t'aime bien ou violet moi aussi je
t'aime bien envie albert la ville de
vichy seul envoi était attendue celle
possible
ça commence déjà ses fruits de votre
casque rouge ce qui doit motiver des
amateurs on va s'amuser
papa mais oui c'est ça
on a téléphoné non les gendarmes sont
venus les gens donnent de quoi les
gendarmes et de l'hôpital vers l'hôpital
enfin c'est bien la première fois que je
vois madame aussi nerveuse parce que
monsieur se baladait la chasse avec
monsieur roger pourtant monsieur ne
risque rien il est adroit si roger
j'espère bien alors pour qui ce café au
lait ça ce qu'a fait les messieurs
jacques lui qui d'habitude est très tape
une heure et un break est un peu la
barbe avec ses croissants croustillant
et bien ce matin et dit qu'il ait loué
basse vallée du parti moi même son café
au lait il est présentable je peux
entrer dans sa chambre
quoi que veut dire ce moment je peux
dire madame je sais qu'elle savait que
sera pas puisqu'elle ne comprendra six
joyet monsieur jacques pour présenter à
vous tomberez raids dans les pommes il
n'aura qu'à moi c'est bon et ben allez
vous calmer en balayant la salle à
manger sur le camion rappeur et je vais
vous dire une chose
mon métier aussi pour un métier c'est
pourquoi toutes les femmes devraient
faire à tour de rôle 18 mois comme au
service militaire
ainsi quand je serai mariée je pourrais
espérer pour la balayer ma cuisine la
fille d'un baron et d'une baronne et
c'est comme ça le petit jésus voulait
que la vie s'organise sur la terre aussi
les baron et la baronne de ce temps là
il va union le couple et si on
commençait par vous couper le centre ça
serait pas du temps perdu passive à tous
et bonne mine à monsieur jacques alors
l'avait pas raison comme toujours la
joséphine bella réseau tu as une mine à
faire peur à l'aube ce matin je les ai
regardés partir mais j'en tremble encore
c'était le froid mon chou à froid près
c'est qu'ils pénètrent jusqu'à l'os les
a regardés doit aussi porter j'ai dû me
lever pour réconforter ce pauvre orange
fait il avait une mine comme la tienne
le pauvre est comme toi il n'a pas voulu
manger sans l'énergie d'albert il ne
serait pas allé chasser
doit-on café au lait non pendant
l'exécution d'un homme que tu a condamné
à mort non non je ne peux pas mais si le
bon dieu n'avait pas voulu que j'envoie
albert à la chasse est lui en réalité
qualité assez captiva prise de force et
la première fois je n'aurais pas été si
tu peux fait par la surprise j'aurais pu
te gifle et de prêter de bougâa et de
prier de chercher un autre ménage pour
passer le reste de t bag d'une craint
pas que le bon dieu ton voire plus tard
chercher le paradis ailleurs quelque
part du côté de l'enfer mais le bon dieu
ne m'a jamais dit personnellement qu'est
ce que j'ai été dans l'obligation de
machines et ce matin fut interdite
comment l'église ne te répète pas tous
les jours qu'il est interdit de tuer son
prochain l'église avec tous les cadavres
derrière elle à travers les siècles
laisse moi rire tu n'as jamais lu la
bible
je suis bien sûr nora salomon oui le
fils du roi david leroy d'avis david et
goliath qui n'a jamais entendu parler
d'eux au cinéma bon eh ben on va david
aimé une femme mariée
alors il a envoyé le mari tu as un
traquenard à la guerre moi petit
bourgeois je ne pouvais pas envoyer
albert tout seul dans un traquenard à la
guerre alors j'ai transcrit l'histoire
de belles âmes et en style bourgeois
j'envoie albert à l'achat et quand
j'entrerai au paradis c'est david au
bras de bethsabée kim en ouvrira lui
même les portes tandis que toi avec ta
méconnaissance des véritables problèmes
moraux qui aurait empêché de naître le
fils de david et de belles âmes et le
grand roi salomon
doit-on café au lait alors d'après toi
on devrait tuer tous les cocus de la
terre eh ben j'ai peut-être pas beaucoup
de lecture mais je suis célibataire et
je sais compter et alors je me rends
compte de la boucherie tiens ton père at
il tué sa mère m'a pas tué maman
pourquoi parce que papa tron maman du
matin au soir
quoi mais la petite gourde c'est sa
maîtresse relays est surpris hier et
d'après joséphine il en avait nulle une
nouvelle ici tous les ans rené c'est la
dernière en date est humain la forme
aujourd'hui seulement maintenant qu'il
est trop tard trop tard tu comprendras
des mariannes moi mon père a une
maîtresse et je ne la savait pas toi tu
le savais qu'il me le disait par pardus
crétion là on ne parle pas comme une
femme du monde
goody que tu fais tir est amarrée comme
un lapin qui vous écris de trahison
parce que ton père un lâche de ta mère
s'offre une petite amie ça on peut dire
que tu ne te poses pas à des problèmes
ben écoute si tu veux je te réponde
explique doit clairement hier encore
j'aurais pu interroger mon père lui
demander comment il avait surmonté ses
remords ses scrupules
comment il avait pu laisser vivre maman
et sur la tuer parce qu'il la trompait
exactement
jean tu auras été deux fois responsable
de la mort de ce pauvre albert mois
tu vis vraiment à la hauteur de la
digestion et de la respiration est ce
que tu appelles l'amour ça doit être
tout juste une autre façon de respirer
papa jeanneret de m'apprendre à
l'instant que tu as une maîtresse que
d'études cette jeune personne qui mange
à table avec maman la petite renault oui
la petite renault y en a plusieurs
vous êtes un [ __ ] monsieur moussa
c'est la dernière fois que me conduit en
gentleman avec une intellectuelle
maisons les plus bavards sont sensibles
à une certaine solidarité masculine mais
si j'ai parlé c'était pour arranger les
choses et il a parlé trop tard hélas bon
je vais t'expliquer salaire bien vous
êtes trop monsieur à qui il dit vous
confier ma fille ce secret qui ne nous
appartenait pas mais nous sommes en
plein gâchis que responsable je suis
demandé la votre fille
mon père me connais assez pour ne pas
douter de ma volonté d'éclaircir la
situation ma chère petite fille
adieu monsieur car j'espère ne plus vous
revoir ta puissiez vous être bons
prophètes et sigean sort indemne
qu'elles le sont alors papa ben voilà
c'est encore été un garçon et une fille
bon bah laisse moi te dire tout de même
que en dépit des apparences cette petite
rené à une belle arme bouleversée par un
trouble très attachant mais ce n'est pas
la question de maman dans cette histoire
le regard de maman quand ils se poussent
sur toi j'adore ta mère moi aussi j'aime
albert juste furieux c'est ton mari et
ma dans les pattes à femmes une chance
que je respecte
c'est pourquoi je tiens avant tout on
estime que le banc crois tu que maman
tes skis bras encore quand elle
apprendra que la chroniqueuse la presse
c'est avec un soin d'amoureux que
surveille la tranquillité de tous mais
tu savais à combien d'heures de bonheur
je renonce pour qu'elle puisse en toute
ignorance continuer sa petite vie
douillette et quelle ignorance toi tu le
sais ne sais quoi que tu latron à ce
qu'ils ont accepté de vivre dans le
mensonge et le caractère douteux mère si
vous voyez quelque chose je n'étais pas
le résigner à cette lâcheté qui
m'écoeure note que j'approuve savez la
transition est rentré quotidienne pour
ne parle pas fait d'histoires comme moi
pas le rétameur études à lyon me rendra
pas parce que c'est la confusion dans
laquelle tu vis me fait pitié enfin pas
de regret qu'une mort a été hélas
d'aucun secours que ce coin du rejoint à
propos d'albert camus
comment ce petit syndicaux qui ne
méritait pas aux raids de tromper albert
est parfait et c'est moi qui seront
commence le 3 et je ne peux pas le
supporter qu'est ce que ne peut pas
supporter
si dans l'incertitude tu ne veux pas
insinuer que que tu aurais un amant toi
ma fille
ma fille que je revois encore avec des
petits cheveux bouclés tombe
naturellement vers le champ des dix ans
montceau ma fille mes rêves ses traits
dans les bras d'un homme qui n'est même
pas manchot benhima a été la proie d'une
crise déjà unique jaloux j'y vois là
tout d'un coup très solide un homme que
je ne connais même pas et oui qu'il
craignait annoncé je connaissais je
tuerai j'y ai pensé avant toi mais ce
n'était pas à lui de mourir
toi qui a une si bonne petite nature si
franche c'est exigeant troisième j'ai
gardé toutes mes exigences
ainsi quand tu imagines que maman peut
tout apprendre à de dérivation ah bon je
suis un homme
ensuite ta mère est chrétienne mais pour
les chrétiens le pardon est obligatoire
et ça ne suffit ou du non-respect
d'envisager toutes les solutions
possibles
aurai-je manqué de patience car ce
pauvre albert aussi été chrétien ah oui
mais c'est un homme et en apprenant la
vérité pourrait sortir plus marie
caucasiens laisse-moi analyser la
situation
si ça fait adopter le point de vue
chrétien la honte du péché me conduisait
à confesse la confession à la pénitence
la pénitence à l'absolution et je
pouvais recommencer le lendemain avec
une nouvelle pureté mais tu n'aurais pas
eu le droit de recommencer
alors c'était impossible parce que tu
penses que c'est essayer ce bar sont
assez beau est complètement inculte mais
autre chose me le rend aussi
indispensable que notre pain quotidien
et d'autre part à bien y réfléchir
la morale chrétienne n'est pas assez
sérieuse pour moi oh bah si elle était
sérieuse depuis 2000 ans qu'alain
terville adultère noir est une base de
ce travail et toutes les concubines des
rois de france aurait-elle été béni par
les archevêques qui continue des
archevêques
on discute encore un problème quel
bonheur vous dérange pas
non au contraire je vous attendais avec
une impatience avez vous un père bien
sûr il est si bon pour moi
ils m'adorent lui aussi
mais tous les partis mauvaise nouvelle
il n'est pas malade mais parlez vous
m'effrayé il n'avait jamais pensé au
père de la petite rhône et l'alsace
je veux plus te voir je touche à son but
si c'est pas ben ils participèrent du
scandale car parfois ils se saoulent et
c'est tout ce qu'il dit papa n'est pas
venu faire des misères mais il a plu
cadre à ce mois ci est un libre j'ai
l'âge à ta fille mais selon n'est pas
une solution j'attendais de toiles de
réponses claires je te découvre dans une
bagarre tout en mêlée avec la bonne foi
de maman les pertes de tes petites amies
les malheurs de ta fille mes malheurs de
monsieur malheur de ma fille ou votre
père semble en plein cauchemar
quand on se regarde de soi même tout à
coup face à face c'est toujours un
cauchemar face à face viens mode miroir
le mac apporte à des champignons à
majorité jeune et champignons pour
déjeuner votre maman des champignons que
j'ai ramassé moi-même cours l on y soit
601 et rien côté des chaînes où ils sont
toujours bons à ce qu'on dit moi même
pour les champignons votre père non plus
alors je m'emballe pas votre père non
plus évidemment on a laissé entendre
qu'elle les aimait à la crème chercher
dû préparer à ma façon
bon bah allez dont les préparer avec
joséphine est ce que vous voyez votre
maman à la fois je l'adoré en même temps
et nos gènes ou plutôt j'ai des
scrupules alors ce petit cadeau de
champignons rien que pour elle s'est un
peu apaisée ma conscience que vous avez
vu monsieur jacques le cauchemar de mon
georget quel malheur makem temps et vos
rêves
[Applaudissements]
vous ne croyez pas que la petite rené à
son tour ne puisse pas supporter le
regard de votre mère je ne comprends pas
vous aviez inventé un accident de chasse
qui sait s'il n'est pas en train avec
ses champignons d'organiser un accident
de cuisine ce n'est pas impossible à
midi au déjeuner je mangerai juste dans
l'oeuf à la coque
que je ferais cuir moi même à chacun ses
problèmes gelé peuvent être adressés cas
l'existence de mon mari à la mi année à
labrousse je vous en supplie ne vous
occupez pas de la mienne je suis un
solitaire
désolé d'être retiré en ce moment hors
de sa solitude tout de suite c'était
pouvoir parce que je vous disais oui
sans retenue de la chasse aux
champignons champignons les champignons
d'un petit rhône y croyez vous que les
gens dire et prévenante avec moi ah mais
non il s'agit de ton bonheur la petite
fille est ton honneur
laissez-nous par faveur monsieur ou
madame mais c'est une faveur pour moi
alors pourquoi rifle du cifor ma p'tite
cocotte ensuite m'attendais à une telle
folie top pas mais quatre folie où tu ne
m'aimes donc plus haut - demont autant
quand on avait une faiblesse pour un
beau garçon et qu'on pouvait plus se
retenir d'en parler c'est à sa mère
qu'on se confessait est ce qu'un homme
peut nous comprendre ces bêtes les
hommes même ton père et on annonce il
est encore célibataire
quand il sera marié une comprendra plus
sa femme enfin mon petit toit qui a fait
des ics in your tu as encore que les
hommes admettent tous mpt quand il
papillonne et n'admet plus rien quand
ils sont pas connues il ne s'agit pas de
papillonnage possible mais tombeur vient
de faire une seule affreux 4 il est
reproché à toi d'être ta mère avant lui
qu'il est mon père c'est lorsque je lui
répondu alors que me tue ton pauvre papa
est vexé surtout lui qui manque
d'expérience il faut qu'ils toutes les
femmes de la terre ont été sa mère sa
femme et sa fille je viens de le laisser
avec la petite blonde qui est si gentil
elle était en train de divorcer dieu
sait ce qui va lui raconter ma petite
fille avant tout nous devons être bonne
et comme nos maris ne peuvent pas
supporter notre vie privée
on doit la leur cas su même prise en
flagrant délit n'avoue pas comme une
méchante commune méchant qui
d'hondschoote votre mari il reprend je
vous reproche t il tout mon à rythme
d'evans mon père d'être une fille thème
ripd hommes et femmes scrupuleuses car
il reconnaissait le début que c'était
une scrupuleuse
quand il y avait encore mon mari dans ma
vie pour la première fois ça fait rire
on vous le comprenez
le partage quand j'y pensais je lui
disais je dégote égaux à votre mari mais
non georges votre annonce ap le jour 2
puisque st georges
du coup je me dégoûtait en pleurer
georges me disait si tu te dédie des
pâtes une dégoûterait c'est parce que tu
débutes que tu me dégoûtes pas
d'aujourd'hui il vient de me dire il me
donne envie de vomir thermiquement ben
ça vient faire un homme qui est né pour
la wii il les adorait mes larmes il et
buvaient mes larmes de la députation et
aujourd'hui encore maintenant tout de
suite
il vient de me dire il me donne envie de
vomir terriblement mais alors comment
trouver mon mari lui tint qu'il a
transigé trompé mon mari si c'est pas la
vôtre mais en plus tu a poussé cette
petite a trompé son mari s'était pas la
première qui après la grande victime de
l'an dernier y compris celles déjà fait
et la grande roue qui nous le reproche
aussi d'être une star je vois vraiment
pas ce que vous voulez dire prémanon
pourquoi mon mari vous conseille éthique
de tromper vous que je vienne sa
maîtresse à lui lui qui à georges il
s'est fait depuis six mois et
aujourd'hui me rapproche croyez vous il
faut pas vous laisser faire là non je le
ferai pas
le rappeur des georges guille makoum
mais que georges parler d'une autre vous
ne voulez pas dire jean votre genre ce
serait mon job tu fais une maîtresse à
montlaur mauvaise 58 via la normale ont
rapporté via il m'a dit dis toi sur ce
que tu te fous lui retâter tous les deux
tout de blanc parce que je donnerai tout
le choc
enfin devant ta femme sa fille et sa
maîtresse retenez que ce problème que je
te pose est tout à l'heure est un vrai
problème est que tu n'as pas su le
résoudre oh je croyais avoir entendu un
coup de feu
tétouan une plaque et trompait osé
femmes 17 ans au duo vicieuse ici chez
toi je suis sa fille y avait tant de
respect pour vous mais c'est bien le
moment de parler de respect mais vous
aviez été le grand amour de sa jeunesse
ne devait pas être digne de goumois le
grand amour de sa vie il ya eu trop
fatigué at on peur ce que je pense d'eux
il le sait
et moi qui croyais et du temps j'ai plus
qu'à votre euro dollar qui vous
établissez le bilan de votre vie comment
prépare ses bagages avant un long voyage
au plus
mais non mais me croyais est ce nous
regardent de genre et de baby brami la
première et la dernière montée j'ai vous
faisant plaisir
je voyais plein moi et toi tu es ça toi
aussi
j'étais la seule interdite à savoir et à
croire que tu mets mon but du géant
serbe a bien vu que brice parmi les
étoiles pour cette seule raison c'est
madame qui déjà nous de ton bonheur tu
es tu vas sombre ce petit gars se tutoie
le bonheur de ton père notre droit à
nous tourner catastrophe mon petit papa
tu sembles vraiment déconcertés ah oui
je tue pas fâché qu'elle te juge tapis
toi qui juge les femmes car ils vous
reprocher d'être une femme que j'étais
avec lui et que vous étiez due forme
les boîtes étaient si fiers depuis quand
une famille où l'on pouvait tout se dire
je vous respecte à je vous admire et et
immoraux des heureux
la chanteuse où je dirais que les 30 le
sais moi à lui facilement dépendrait pas
toujours les mêmes solutions qui se
promène on en revient toujours à ce
point unique faire disparaître l'horreur
à wil à faire disparaître
oh mais je comprends tout tu allais me
les faire manger ses chants des
champignons que tu as mettre un
choisissez soit soigneusement
spécialement pour moi
on s'aimait d'indiquer tout spécialement
hu j'ai pas compris oui avec vos
champignons vous ne les a préparés à la
crème
la petite mort naturelle dire ça moi qui
aurai t il heureux de donner ma vie pour
vous une idée juste aller voir si ça dit
j'avais bien ne peut nous mettre sur la
piste tu lis regarde dans les yeux et
leurs yeux sont pures comme on pouvait
soupçonner j'optimise aux commandes il
la croyait belge et albert tu crois
qu'il peut deviner lui aussi en
regardant qui retrouve sa langue toi
j'ai hâte de me regarder te regarder ce
pauvre albert albert ne pourra plus
jamais me reprocher ma trahison et je
trouve ma fille à l'instant j'ai douté
de moi ton exemple le navrant me
réconforte ne te laisse jamais rien
reproché par un mari et un mari dont je
me méfiais mais moi non plus je me
méfiais pas eu je te regarde à mon tour
albert est devant toi comme un aveu
le mari de rené hauss était un aveugle
alors pourquoi moi aussi dans les
chemins c'est bien un groupe devant toi
ô comble tout vérose soupçonné ma vertu
parce que ses maîtresses à lui pour
tromper en a ri oui oui mais pourquoi
pas aussi aurait pu prêter comme toutes
les autres convives y contempler dont
leur mari mais mon m
fier quand vous regarde très lu chez
parmi vos mensonges et vos suspicion moi
j'aurais su découvrir que la vérité la
mort se donne toujours le bras et
j'aurais su voir clair avec talent jeu
du show on vous demande un téléphone au
téléphone et bien cette nouvelle que je
fais ça tu rentres avec dieu sait quel
chagrin je la prendrai aussi grâce à
vous some more voici médias par
téléphone
monsieur monsieur jacky voulu parler une
dernière fois vous qui voulez vous les
courbes et oui alors quelle maison voir
clair voir clair avec cas c'est à mon
tour aujourd'hui d'y voir clair
avec ap petite variante est où ta pa
pascal bien à voir et revoir et dont
messi de taxi d'affilée de ta race par
le mois dans michel qu'elle me michel
d'yvetot
d'abord c'est une demande qu'elle michel
d'yvetot c'est que déjà je découvre la
vérité quelle vérité parce que tu es un
menteur je suis une menteuse kadhafi
avait raison voilà où même les mots
semblent d autres à la suspicion
générale tu vas me répond oui c'est
normal quoi voulez mais vous la
revenante
d'abord il est mort michel filteau on
n'a pas le droit d'aller déterrer les
morts pour excusez les fautes des
vivants mais attendre qu'une femme soit
viable pour lui reprocher ça le jeu buzz
soutient madame guigou pourrait se
passer si on utilise ça c'est pas
possible vous ne touchez pas à mon
piédestal
d'abord taf il était même pas nous alors
moi non plus et mon mari me reproche une
faute dont je me souviens pas avec un
homme hors du temps où ça me mettrait ce
n'était point tout en concevant et le
jour wemhoff en cadeau d'anniversaire à
connexion de champignons doit cette
jeune personne mais la bassine et de
l'écriture pillon madame 10/10/10
rapporté pour la manger toute entière
devant vous oui je veux que mes dames 18
sache que je ne suis pas une menteuse
moi et je veux qu'elle me regarde
pendant tout le temps que je mangerai
tous mes champignons
ik proches l'avouent pas manger ces
champignons tout cru
yop ont bien c'est déjà poison n'était
pas prête à vous dire que je
t'embrouille et je vais la reconquérir
votre confiance est monté près de vous
sur le piédestal
ça fait mal à ces gens meurent je ne
fais pas une perte sur sa loi qui aurait
dit si heureuse de mourir à votre place
au moins que tu te remuant proche là
comment vois tu es bon tu veux qu'elle
me jure mesdames dit que si je me
réponds sera c'était pas de la jalousie
c'était une erreur de botanique in error
culinaire vous de la q2 fait de cuisine
c'est exact madame qui dit se lavent la
vaisselle moi même mais je ne vous
quitterai pas avant d avoir mangé tous
jusqu'au dernier si tu ne rebâtit -
cannaweed mobile homes ont chargé près
console et que je serai enfin vivante au
centre du grand mystère afin d'apprendre
les secrets de ma naissance
il est passage sur les terres pendant le
xxème siècle
duncan mais le corps dans une agitation
cette attente est pire que tout tu paies
un homme jeune écroulement un
écroulement en train de s'écrouler dans
le bruit l'étonnement et la touche
j'ai vécu parmi des bottes retour est de
moscou et toi même tu ne mentait pas
j'avais besoin de vérité chez les autres
toi tu te trompe son mari voilà la
vérité ça c'est ignoble et athée trop
marrant c'est du cristal les autres le
diront c'est pour la mer jaune si
maintenant avait eu un accident dans sa
vie correct et choisit la prendre et
supporter les terribles la remorque de
ta femme ou bien mourir en toute
connaissance de cause sans hésiter
j'aurais préféré la mort merci mon petit
papa
même après 30 ans quand la certitude
vous atteint on a envie d'en crever et
pas éternisé envie de t'embrasser
pourquoi ne suis-je pas moi mais va
savoir que vous êtes si on reste des
tentes envoyées aux amoureux 3g dans
raison d'attendre en ce moment la mort
d'albert lord albert et parce que tu l'a
trompée voilà que tu souhaites en plus
la mort d'albert et là c'est sans la
souhaiter que j'ai été dans l'obligation
de l'organiser de l'organiser oui mais
d'organiser quoi c'est un comble parce
que je suis une femme honnête qui essaie
d'être logique est en train de me
raconter du sens pour faire peur albert
en venir oui j'ai pris hier roger de
ramener si son corps le corps d'albert
avec tous ces problèmes résolus
y compris les problèmes métaphysiques il
ne se posait pas
comment toi ma fille tu as fait un sens
inné albert est ce le premier homme qui
meurt d'être trop aimer les bras m'en
tombent du corps et son âme se détache
du sien juste effet le pressentiment de
la famille vient d'arriver
s'il vient d'arriver merci dans le chas
des gendarmes sont là oui avec ce pauvre
monsieur roger houioux n'est pas fier
jeanne et du chagrin pour lui donc nous
ne rêvions pas et aucun miracle était
possible et j'aurai vécu pour faire
naître une fille qui a écrit mais sans
permis a ramené de force au besoin de
six rangées au parce que c'est rangé que
tu avais chargé c'est bien ça les amis d
enfance quand il sentira comptez vous
connaissez la nouvelle wii pour ça je
connais la nouvelle ka neige ou si vous
saviez que je me sens soulagée j'ai bien
je n'ai pas l'âme d'un policier sans me
souvenir en temps voulu ce soulagement
la rentrée puisque c'est ici qu'on doit
vous avez je suis désolé l'allemagne
elle et sa maman semble qu'un menteur
humbert le pas mort non mais pendant cet
animal fait tout ce qu'il fallait pour
ça vous entendez madame j'ai tout fait
mme richmond n'en rajoute pas bon il ya
deux rajoutera à opel
il s'était dit on voulait pas revenir à
la maison si tu veux faire a mené par
les gendarmes
merci mes amis et à bientôt
alors faut retirer la plainte était pour
l'obliger à retirer à la maison et je me
permets de vous offrir un coup face aux
défis quotidiens du sud dans votre
domaine et les débouchés pour une bonne
bouteille tout ce qu'ils voudront avec
nos salutations
[Rires]
si vous voulez pardonner aux matelles me
dire à 17 il alors déporté m'avait dit
ça les gars et tu m'excuseras ensuite
auprès de ta femme à partir sans revoir
et avec sa fille à ce moment là nous
rencontrent les gendarmes
une idée m'est venue j'aurais raconté
que y avait voulu tuer mais comment
cette idée vous at elle traversé
l'esprit mon jean parce que vous répétez
que cet idiot a failli tuer il faut
apprendre à vue samedi à paris m'appelle
on n'est ce pas une seconde il laisse
tomber son fusil vers l'est ils veulent
rattraper la crosse miroite comme dans
les malles à l'acrobate à l'effet que
nous avons eu très peur pour moi mais
sinon son bras qu'il a flanqué tout à
décharge
allez au moins un élu eelv on pourrais
je te jure c'est quoi qui l'avait dans
le crabe les ans et madeleine
j'espère que vous le mettez pas en doute
la parole d'albert c'est toi tu vois que
paris madame est très compréhensif à
quoi l'ex idole de l'accident surtout
avec ce cessna vous le rappelle voilà
tout d'abord je suis n'a fait qu'une
journée ripage compris regarde le visage
ravagé de ce pour roger us ou bien moi
aussi je souffre lui de quoi il a osé
tripoter sont jugés à tort et à travers
jeux le même recommandé le polar mais
son plus haut des cieux à l'être au
trident
oui je l'aï larve s'emberlificoter pilot
une branche d'al ces gens soient la
crosse dans les omoplates il veut se
rapprocher coupable d'avoir compris que
papa nous la raconter trois fois de
suite la coupe il reçoit tous les pour
le bras
malgré tout les champignons ariston des
six mois j'ai pensé qu à tout va en
reprendre pour vous ma rivale fait des
étiers à l'endroit de comptes andré
recommancer donc je suis désolé contre
lequel a mis des licornes et embrassez
vous tout à l'heure tu as l'air au 1er
détenteurs de mandats joséphites de
retirer un mail et grimpe longue tournoi
il en a l'habitude quand elle entre par
d'autres pas et glee est vrai avait pas
bêtement genre ah si tous les maris
étaient comme vous mais où est passé ton
père les deux canards
c'est bon ça doit gérer vos livres
serait plus jamais blanc plus jamais ça
chez vous le demande moi même si vous
distraire qu'il invente une autre
distraction car je te le répète l'ipad
nul ne veut pas mais c'est un miracle
que tu sois pas mais au contraire
répéter encore me répéter je te demande
d'assister ainsi albert vous le dit lui
même qui est évident c'est un miracle a
bien mais tapis sans contredit miracle
de dieu crochète ont fusé de secondes
plus tôt j'y pensais et vous l'entendez
marie madeleine il va sauver c'était ce
qu'on d'inattention d'hésitation
j'hésitais mois en fait été complètement
folle et maintenant alors dites nous
donc une chance pas pu te dire que
prochaine mais ne dit pas un ta femme
que j'étais affolé il est pardon pardon
mon mieux admet et avant même que le
foot soit parti mais je prends la
bretelle gigantesque la concernant et
tout s'arrangera sauf les difficultés
financières pour tous a demandé hier
soir de donner mon petit paquet le petit
paquet bon je veux un petit bac es mon
heure pour vos coffres danger à ne rien
ne presse mon cher ce sera pour mon
prochain voyage non ce qui est fait
n'est plus à faire et puis ce matin par
la faute de saclay roger ce matin j'ai
bien failli et on est avec moi j'en ai
pour une seconde année déjà maintenant
je vous attend ici
non non sexiste et moi mais mon petit
paquet pour le remettre tout de suite
pour être débarrassés contre la frôler
la mort on désire toujours tenir devant
soi des affaires en ordre et consoles ce
pour ranger un qui pense m a les bras
qu'on les hirondelles tu me feras
toujours eu
albert ii l'a dit lui même j'ai fait un
gros effort mais tirer dans le dos d'un
ami le matin à jeun pose des problèmes
inattendus
mon petit roger m'avait rapporté mon
mari attacked vous serez donc bien
aimable de me rendre aussi mon or tel
que je vous l'avait confié je ne peux
pas je tombe de désastre désastre je ne
l'est plus votre ambition devant la
vierge avait confié à mon banquier ce
matin votre banquier qui a le même âge
est parfait c'est curieux à ce salon qui
nous inspire confiance la réveiller
notre monarque tout de suite collé le
voici
comme vous l'avez devant du camp selon
bertrand en plomb de l'alchimie à
l'envers vous montrer les mêmes services
demandés par un sport et que direz-vous
albert pour lui expliquer que son coffre
évident voilà ça ne serait pas là et moi
je sais ce que c'est de partir at-elle
et g urgent et moi je lui dirai la
vérité qu'il veut de moi lundi nous y
sommes
albert vient d'apprendre sa ruine
rien n'est plus dangereux que la bourse
et les banques
la mairie m'a tellement con françois
éviter ça si les passionnés ils parlent
encore avec marie-madeleine qu'il a la
vie dure pas commencer je suis robin et
je suis et toi avec l'amour est bien
contente
nous partirons ensemble d'intérêts moi
seul ici c'est pourquoi pascal bourdiaux
messti cra tels que vous pourrez
demander recommencer ses explications
vous pourquoi voulez-vous gorée vont
vous à vos lèvres
papillon mais ces paquets c'est sûr nous
avons eu un ballon plus aucun nerfs
pourquoi l'appel du pas la police nature
un jour j'ai bossé pas au lit tous les
coups et si tu retournes examinées dont
en faisant renaître a du mal à regarder
damman et du maintien des biogaz dans tu
as raison mon riz rouge et noir j'ai
aimé césaire difficile mais une
obligation impérieuse ou l'enlever de la
bouche je viens recevoir un télégramme
vous aussi vous ne partirez pas et la
valise de roger aussi restera ici que
voulez-vous frayant pauvre albert que
puisse faire d'autres lui expliquer
devant vous la vérité vous lancez pas
elle est capable de tout à cause de
votre hésitation
albert va apprendre qu'il a été trompé
et que son ami d'enfance a voulu
l'assassiner
on earth sera vendu ou chérie mais hélas
ce qui te rendre à la joie de ton amour
et ton bonheur de vivre le gore à tous
les deux vous l'aurez bien voulu genou
il ça n'est même pas certain que
l'avenir et pitié de nous offrait le
père
[Musique]
à cause de 3g soupçonné et la vertu de
tamil n'en parle mais je te pardonne tes
soupçons d'un congé toi les jeunes
femmes qui me consoler de mon âge sont
tout à coup apparu étrangers qui a dû
chercher ailleurs
n'était ce pas là près de toi pour te
consoler voilà ce pauvre monsieur o
toutes les sauces mais sois prudent ce
soit brillant
est-ce que tu as mais rappelle la
prudence celles mensonge pas du tout
c'est une certaine manière d'expliquer
les choses
il arrive avec toi mon char reçu ni les
larmes de ses deux yeux
et puis il vaut toujours le vide le vide
invite toujours le vide un vide terrible
je n'ai jamais rien vu d'aussi terrible
que le vide d'un coffre fort des dunes
aussi cher albert hall i n'est plus que
ruines et dans son jargon tu dirais tu
dirais déshonoré je vais passer pour un
idiot
ils ne croiront pas qui ça ils les
membres du syndicat
tu es syndiqués des syndicats ces a lieu
un syndicat très riche qui était très ch
le syndicat napoléon comme ce que les
amis ou ceux que nous connaissions un
garçon dans le circuit tabitha torje ils
m'ont demandé voici six premiers sacs
doivent appartenait l'autre était la
propriété du syndicat napoléon sadika
d'amis qui croiront jamais que j'étais
voilées sont des hommes sérieux c'est
super j'aurais voulu temps être heureux
avec toi jusqu'à la fin c'est bien ce
que j'avais espéré moi même le sombre
non c'est pas possible
honte à voler ton or on m'a volé ma
purger pour vous mais on ne me servait à
rien à perdre et non mais je me savais
riches est ta femme pouvait vivre sans
trouble et tout comme moi moi aller vers
eux un homme pas une oeuvre a été dur
d'ailleurs on a fait les premiers pas de
mots on dit toujours il est dur en
affaires tu n'as jamais vu avec
amélioration
un homme dont on disait c'est un mot
en affaires et l'économie tout fait mais
tout faire parce que je comprends aux
postes qu'ils se marient je vais aider à
comprendre
merci imagine un homme tue un autre
homme voit la tour 10 octobre et la
torre c'est évident mais qui peuvent
aussi lui donner raison
ça ne ressuscite pas de morts mais ça
peut te rapporter une médaille si tu
soldats oui c'est très gentil chaud pour
les copains jouent ce dimanche en coupe
alors toujours rien oui toujours
profiter je me contente de peu voilà je
cherchais madame et madame guide et
jetteront toutes les deux ensemble alors
je suis content mais c'est monsieur
jacquet me suis rangé qui veulent vous
voir pour vous dire au revoir parce
qu'il sent bon sens là et tous les deux
jacques à roger je vous interdit à ses
filles de leur rendre leurs valises
alors que mme à la mairie avec madame ça
mais la commission doit rendre à lyon
vous soyez de aussi via la
cocotte-minute mater je n'ai pas besoin
de toi maman ma fille on a toujours
besoin de sa mère et tu le comprendras
définitivement quand vous serez plus
l'adulte
c'est pas vrai que monsieur jacquet
monsieur roger ils veulent pas les voir
pas du tout mais musée c'est plutôt de
partir sur la pointe des pieds sans
faire de bruit non c'est l'autre qui
veut vous voir pour vous dire au revoir
l'autre mademoiselle rhône est comme moi
je comprends tout j'ai pensé qu'elle
préfèrerait pouvoir sonne pour vous dire
au revoir
alors j'ai expédié vous deux autres
femmes où est elle seagate a les
histoires des autres c'est intéressant
pas autant que celle qui nous arrive à
nouméa mois il arrive jamais rien mais
c'est nous josé fait mais je sais c'est
toujours de trois êtres marquise avec un
marquis baronne avec un parent mais pas
tant que ça malone a dit bonjour j'ai je
croyais déjà partie sous te dire adieu
pourquoi dieu laisse les drames
s'apaiser peut-être ils rencontraient
encore eu le cours de mon type racing et
trompait madame dig it
ah non jamais avant tu ne trompait pas
attends je croyais qu'elle nous
approuverait avait tous besoin aussi de
tout raconter hockey news approuvent
je priais puisque ce thème et
qu'elle-même réparé ce que je te mets et
tout s'est écroulé
mais nous ne reverrons quand même jamais
ces derniers vous comment pouvait tuer à
la fois être jaloux de ta femme et il
met un petit rené mais j'étais pour toi
qu'un jouet une jolie petite poupée
barbie perfectionnée du marché tu parles
il disait mot georges a comme les autres
bespoke pas maman non non non cependant
martin
j'aurais été si heureuse de mourir avec
toi le même jour à la même heure
tu aurais su bien su m'expliquer au fur
et à mesure les paroles du bon dieu et
quand le bon dieu te donnera ses
explications elles sont à ta porte et tu
pourras comprendre tout seul
il serait donc si cette les mystères du
monde je sais il s'empresse de renvoi tu
les as vus non je pensais à autre chose
regarder mais il me disait un dieu avec
sa valise il pas devant vous c'est vous
qui est devant nous parce que j'ai tous
les torts de mots codés qui ferait en
plus la brutaliser c'est fini même temps
là ta souffrance et à la mort moi votre
détresse de leur séparation
vous savez j'ai failli mourir ce matin
en plus votre mère habite imaginer que
j'espérais l'anc aux années ne me donnez
pas la dernière minute le regret de ne
pas avoir eu cette pensée tout seul dans
mon for intérieur et de notre propre
chef du trône ne vaut un petit rené
c'est empoisonneuse qui avoue ne crie
pas au juge pour la russie avec eux mais
dans un même panier avec sept ont voulu
re moi c'est possible bougez vous dire
aussi ce que vous êtes vous n'êtes pas
déception ou reprenez matin il pleure sa
patrie bonjour j'ai tu sais que le
bonhomme a toujours on voit si je vais
pleurer toute la nuit avec délice
heureusement chagrin ireland en petit
nom bravo madame qu'il n'avait pas de
mémoire j'ai voulu apprendre qu on peut
joindre à plusieurs dans une même tu es
assis en dépit des apparences
si vous croyez que je vous laisse votre
georges et vous vous trompez je leur
porte avec une loi oui cela porte votre
mari dans ma valise mon corps
mon coeur mon âme puis cette porte vous
gêne je te garderai avec n'importe plus
jeune tu joues tu sais que tu me garde
tout athènes comme un trésor
voilà le vrai problème voulez vous
fichez le camp oui mais je voulais si
c'est mon ordre et mon souvenir mais je
tends porte avec tout le pr passé mon
genre g et elle s'emporte
c'est si bouleversée je serais plus
encore si je pensais moi aujourd'hui que
je vais en réclamait elle sait importer
que la dame certain sens qui se perd un
peu dans l'image
et quand maman va te coffret car
désormais n'espère plus aller acheter
son journal ça qu'elle s'accompagne elle
ne pourra pas s'empêcher de penser à
cette fille il ya toutes les autres
femmes que tu as connu dans mon domaine
dans un grand silence et jacques si je
le laisse filer m'en porterais lui aussi
avec lui à naujac ne partira pas tu vas
pas conserver ton amant chez toi avec sa
simplicité
la petite rené m'a découvert un horizon
la simplicité du génie qu'on reste plus
être athée idiote pour condamner à mort
ce pauvre albert alors que c'est dans la
cervelle de gens il vit mon péché tout
est arrangé je peux partir à cacao tout
mon travail est accompli
albert est un homme mort de mourir et
c'est vous la chasse à mollau l'accident
de chasse du gibier deux femmes une vue
de l'esprit
comment voulez vous qu'un ami au coeur
sensible puisse assassiner son frère en
amitié c'est un effort humain alors
alors albert n'est pas mort pas encore
mais ça vient et la solution était d'une
simplicité qui organise et puisse de
mélancolie j'ai de la peine pour et
albert il est dans sa jambe avec son
fusil il a enfin compris que la vie sans
son nom n'a plus de sens et qu'il doit
mourir une tente de se suicider rendez
vous à venir une nouvelle voici sur un
point d'être délivrés de vos troupes de
conscience du bloc enfin partir
tranquille pas tout de suite prévient
albert que j'ai retrouvé son attention
surtout sonore il ne soit plus une autre
affaire est raté et d'autre part je ne
l'est plus je les confie à mon banquier
l'espace jacques ainsi vous partiriez
avec lors de mon mari avec sonore avec
mon leur sang hwa au plus exactement
avec l'or et moi par dessus de marchés
anormaux je vous laisse ici oui on dit
ça mais l'autre vous emportent tout sur
fond noir je vous jure
roger pour le même prix ces gens qu'il
faut tuer comment voulez vous que je tue
jacques maintenant qu'il est prévenu et
je suis armé jérémy puisque vous voulez
prendre leur prenait aussi les risques
que j'allais comment lui expliquer que
l'aurait retrouvé je ne sont pas des
explications que te demanderas albert
mais son offre attention si vous parlez
c'est la catastrophe il vivra et
apprendra la vérité
histoire et si sans ma permission toutes
absentes et de cette maison jacques les
gendarmes sur ma demande qui ramènerait
ne viendra pas mais l'entourage avait
son nom ne lui allait pas faux espoirs
ne prolongeait pas son mal vanille enfin
auquel semaine ma petite fille ce ne
sont pas les plus belles intelligences
qui pour les plus belles découvertes
am non jacques ne m'apportera pas comme
la petite rené dans un beau rêve
ah non je préfèrerais nous tuer bon ce
serait dommage un si beau garçon ah oui
ce serait dommage alors comment on
l'empêché de partir en restant près de
huit jours
mais s'il s'en va quand même je le
suivrai s'il le faut jusqu'au bout du
monde mais alors et monsieur j'aurai
retrouvé mon or mon amour oui quand
votre père est entré dans la chambre il
avait le canon sur le crash c'est vrai
je les mourir sans même pour pouvoir ne
serait pas tué mais je vous dis que
c'était fait je vous dis que ça va être
fait comme serez pub est ce que tu les
as retour in extremis tout mais louis
xviii
davy tous sont plus dans la valise de
roger qui fera dans ma valise du petit
louis tu ne manques pas fan mais parier
même épouvantable celui-ci donc j'ai
réussi dans ma tâche dit pas inquiet
d'un ratage complet parce que les
acteurs ne sont pas dans ma valise tiens
il vieira suis certaine marival elodie
certaine alors j'aurai volet mois lors
d'albert moins renommés répondait marie
madeleine fille n'est pas inquiet alors
je fais un voleur mois la mairie volet
c'est beaucoup plus grave qu'en tant ses
concurrents explique toi tu es un
raisonnement quelle hypothèse peut
laisser croire à marie madeleine télé
deux sacs d'or pourrait être ma valise
mais c'est moi même qui ai déposé les
acteurs dans la valise de rougeole à toi
plutôt des non plus permis grand jérôme
là
si tu m'as fait des verts ton père me
disait quelque chose avec bonheur et pas
le temps je suis sur mon l'époque albert
pour des raisons graves douloureuse
pathétique j'ai été amené à demander à
grand service à roger un service
difficile je le reconnais roger marchand
d'art et pour ce service difficile
il exigea des 10000 oui mais ce service
difficile il ne me l'a pas rendu alors
ne doit pas t-il pas te rendre crédible
oui d'autres questions que je suis
vraiment motivé le noir n'est pas du
tout un contrat est un contrat et mon
contrat était en cours d'exécution
oui ou non il ya 10 minutes de ma du
paddy ma décision est irrévocable
oui ou non il ya 10 minutes le galon de
fusil et et vincent g cuche et veut
parce que j'étais ruivet alors si vous
avez passé vos 4 amélioré tout le monde
bosse et alors mais puisque paribas dé
la retrouver mais alors pourquoi vous
dites je me veux tu le trouveras ton
lors et mon contrat sera exécuté avec
toi je comprends pas très bien et vous
j'ai horreur de la psychologie c'est que
roger mélange tout
ma p'tite cocotte toi même et tu bien
sûr donc patent vérifier connu roger ce
matin êtes vous revenu de la chasse avec
albert vivant ou avec albert normes que
le beurre vivons je me suis encore
vivant
vous n'avez donc pas rempli votre
contrat donc vous devez rendre ou se
produit je suis grandement nord mais si
tu veux demander un avis quand je
t'aurais pas conseillé de signer un
contrat avec roger tu ne dis jamais que
si rien n'est fait enrhumer sitôt beau
père n'était pas rentré comme un fou
dans la chambre en criant votre aurait
prouvé ou c'est durant ce moment confie
donne dans le pays recule et bâtons que
leur est à moi non le composent et
ratoire puisque c'est simon nora moi ça
fait donc le petit pour le moment je
peux faire la pole et albert lui
s'étirer nage libre messieurs si vous
dis pourra plus parler mais si vous
aviez plus cher aux légumes ou vous ce
soir on mange un avant-goût du cac
4 nous avons vingt deux paires il est en
état de légitime défense économique et
je peux pas pleurotes au nord je ne
l'est plus j'ai confié à mon banquier
dans un bon tu toi oui depuis que j'ai
de l'or ne vois tu trouves un bon pied
ce matin chez toi oh tiens c'est jacques
ça on peut rien contre le destin et le
dessin de 7 ans n'étaient pas d'attendre
à tanger dans les coffres sous la
surveillance des temps meilleurs
comment comment comment comment vous
saviez je devais vous procurer ce matin
d'emile louis on me les vols voleurs ou
les chapeaute vous m'entendez crier vous
ne dites rien on va continuer ma classe
au service des plus hautes personnalités
là s'interroge jamais sur l'origine de
la fortune de s'écrire au 8e rang témoin
mais louis ou si vous percevez vous
savez je compte jusqu'à 3 écoutez il met
extrêmement difficile de prendre des
loups et qui vous ont peut-être
appartenait mais qui à mes yeux sont la
propriété de roger à qui j'ai remis un
reçu des bons joueurs suivent et
jurançon leur ensuite il en disposera
sombre et ça se tient entre extrêmement
voilà le voilà lancé dans ces conditions
cher monsieur roger je vous retrouve
dans notre pauvre fille m'appelle s'en
sortir car j'ai bien peur que tout on ne
remarque non nourrissez londres s'est
merveilleusement lourd semble s'arranger
pourtant je suis inquiet à propos
dis-moi quel service l'étude demandée
c'est l'individu sa surface commerciale
ça devait arriver
mais dit quelque chose toi je lui avais
demandé de te trouver ce matin à la
chasse c'était donc ça lexicon chose il
voulait être payé comme s'il avait
réussi c'est un conte à 10 ans
et toi tu avais accepté peu tué
accidentellement et pour 10000 oui oui
albert tu as jamais été pris dans un
engrenage comme garage à propos
d'antrenas ge quand un client me paye
une voiture je la lui laisser sa voiture
trois atouts livrer la marchandise et ta
conscience ne reprochait rien oui ou non
il ya dix minutes neige pas du tout ce
que je devais dire pour que tu renonces
la vie albert contre livre entraînant
perpétuellement derrière toi c'est de
saad dans la nature mais a su bien dit
mon cher jacques que cette disparition
n'était qu'un malentendu et que la
providence et que je les retrouverai mes
p'tits louis suffit que vous ne
partiriez passion que je voulais confie
t il les avait déjà emporté même avec
fais moi même été sacré en 2008 vous
aviez compte et non non je fais toujours
confiance à mes clients et bien sûr le
nom a changé sur les reçus à la place de
roger jeu mais albert moi je lui
remettais les deux sacs d'or mais avec
une de ses inquiétudes
voilà tout est mis en place irrégulier
six mille anonymes
si un jour vous avez visite des
polyvalents et qu'il tombe sur ce papier
pourrez toujours dire qu'on ne savait
pas de quel halle berry la question est
vraiment je te regarder et là moi je
vais penser aux copains du syndicat pour
respirant librement car il aurait tué
trois femmes tous les mois je fais une
tuer
bon d'accord à terre et j'y songe marie
madeleine pourquoi selon vous les tubes
cher estimé ce sont des idées mon genre
tu perds tu as traversé la tête des
femmes des jt son importance ne partirai
pas nous allons avoir besoin de vous
quote tu veux me plus c'était métro
voilà vous aimez trop auquel fin des
vacances en faisant primer c'est pour
toi de mes esprits j'ai perdu mon or je
les retrouvais bon ensuite tu à payer un
homme pour qui me fascine oui mon amour
que celui-là ce soit chargé de la
besogne n'est pas pour me surprendre
ce n'est pas gentil ce que tu dis là et
qu'il a raté cinq jeunes me surprend
encore moins mais pourquoi pourquoi
l'avoir chargé de cette besogne
parce que j'ai été violée c'est la
grande moyens you lie quand elle a été
violée j'ai été violée barge à un seul
mois de plus amples et violé ma femme
célibataire ne s'est jamais jusqu'à quel
point il viole une femme qui s'offre à
lui en se défendant un peu et l'idée que
tu puisse apprendre cet accident m'a vu
insupportable rendez vous parler c'est
vous qui va augmenter en ce moment
l'accident comment l accident il
accident comme celui de roger ce matin
si jamais tu as fais et je l'apprécié
exactement à la relève de quoi s'agit-il
j'ai été la maîtresse de cet homme est
devant le regard de t bonds cieux si
confiant j'ai souffert j'ai souffert à
tant faire mourir ou moins bon fut sa
pauvre chéri en patois c'est un gendre
parfait et l'idée quand il continuer à
vivre dans l'ignorance pendant que je
continuais à me laisser violer me fait
de plus sorti un sport plus beaux murs
et une compréhension tout à fait
exceptionnelle alors rejet exige à 10000
louis pour me délivrer de mes angoisses
ça
donc donc faisons le point
quoique a rendu l'argent vous et comment
comptes tu es qu'une vous étiez hamouma
phase iia qui a compris ça fait envie
et chez moi chaloupe injurié laisse
digne de toi roger vous avons conduit
retrouve jacques boura votre femme le
bonheur dossier les petits oiseaux ou si
chaud mais aussi pour réfléchir j'ai
bien compris ce qu'est ce qui se passe a
dû demander à ton lorsqu'il a fait
pendant son absence non y est revenue
dans l'île elle aussi mais marie m
jamais le parti comme thierry marie
madeleine on le voit que ce qu'on
imagine et quand on n'imagine rien n'y a
rien ya pas à chercher ailleurs je dois
manquer d'imagination parce que enfin
mme madeleine lui même
hélas oui je t'aime et je ne pensais pas
avant l'arrivée de jacques que je
pouvais tu es mais à ce point vous voyez
mon gendre vous y avez gagné
les femmes ont quelquefois besoin
d'expériences malheureuses pour mieux
comprendre leur véritable bonheur oui
non moi c'est tout de même pas pour me
faire plaisir que ce qu'on colle a
essayé de violer ma femme allait finir
vous savez à douzy fait pas de gros mots
un nom de ta force doit rester calme tu
le
non non et non sa culture est pas au
point d'abord parce que j'aime pas les
histoires et vous voyez marie madeleine
c'est pas commode ma fille mon enfant
mort et bien qu'ils aillent mourir
ailleurs je le tuerais pas notre gendre
et chrétiens qui se marie à l'église et
deux barres d'or il va me [ __ ] le camp
4e hésitation en cinquième face il ya eu
5 ha ben c'est impossible jacques ne
partira pas ma petite fille l'autre
genre qui est très raisonnable peut
difficilement après tes explications
gardait dans son ménage ce célibataire
toi aussi tu doivent être raisonnables
oui j'ai pu j'ai plus rien affairisme
j'ai déjà commis ce que je pense et je
resterai à vivre le reste de ma vie avec
la pensée lancinante qu'à travers ce
vaste monde
mon péché se promènent perpétuellement
redescend dans les souvenirs délicieux
dans votre mémoire je vous jure qu'on
pense de plus jamais à vous se sauve
dans mes cauchemars veufs veuves pour
que tu n'es jamais été le mari d'une
femme coupable par respect de ta mémoire
je les pousse à me demande si malgré de
gros efforts pour venir va l'oublier
sans doute au cours de vos petites
aventures n'avez vous jamais rencontré
une femme qui place l'amour pour son
mari au dessus de tous puisque tu n'en
as pas le courage et prenez une leçon
ranger non mais vous êtes seul par human
head on va voir des tas d'ambiance mais
tous mon fric comme complice pour une
assistance à une personne en garde à vue
mais c'est une utopie
messieurs partir sur ne leur vois plus
jamais j'oublierai est ballot grèce où
ils oublient c'est la mort qui faillit
oublie ratissage lamelle
voilà pourquoi ils m'ont ri je suis trop
vieux qu'on vivra verra
il faut toujours une victime
ranger a fui at elle s'en est tirée vous
exigez la grâce de jacques ce sera dans
mois marie-madeleine la victime enfin
elle a pensé à elle
vous poussez mario celui-ci il a face à
elle se tuera pas non plus après tout
peut-être été dit juste que ce soit moi
qui veut sacrifier je vous passe dessus
de chaque fille tu vis ici mais bien
entendu je dois vivre
est ce ma mort qui effacerait de la
cervelle de cet homme le souvenir de nos
nuits sans sommeil ça serai moi même
tout seul mais alors comment tu le
sacrifier ma petite fille je veux rester
maîtresse du futur de mon passé qui vit
dans le coeur de cet homme m'a pas ta
fille va encore résonner un peu trop à
l'instant même où je serai honnête au
coin du feu près de moi dit bien aimer
un homme respirerait de l'autre côté de
la terre avec les images et les bruits
de mes baisers c'est impossible
et tandis que je serai ici fidèle à mon
mari fidèle j'ai repensé dans sa
solitude elle n'était tout de même pas
mal la petite marie madeleine parent non
je ne laisserai pas jacques partir avec
l'image de mon corps à sa libre
disposition
non je ne laisserai pas se repaître à sa
guise de nos gestes morts donc je ne
laisserai pas rêver à moi sans
surveiller moi-même ses rêves
vous me contre aider à le laisser vivre
alors contraignez moi aussi à le suivre
toujours hélas partout jusqu'au bout du
monde jusqu'au bout de sa fille je suis
comme une tigresse suis un chacal
joséphine mon manteau no ken de panthère
prends tendrement soin de nous si cher
albert jamais mon âme ne quittera ton
dames et dès que ses souvenirs seront
état je reviendrai près de toi vivre
notre éternel amour merci et josé vous
voulez une valise
je ne veux rien emporter que ton image
albert vous prenez les vôtres j'en
profiterai pour surveiller ton nord sas
est une patronne
les nîmois ma vie est gâchée ne vous
l'avez choisi au début de cette histoire
la pureté à n'importe quel prix toutes
les années de femmes ne comprendront
tu crois quelques heures passées devant
et perdez toute espérance
je ne te dis pas adieu mont albert car
c'est près de toi quand esprit je reste
même ma fille nous l'a expliqué c'est
avant tout une femme des vitraux quan
est beaucoup trop connecte au marie
madeleine mais c'est pas possible
elle serait parti avec mon fric et son
amant de nos jours tout est possible
avec de l'instruction
[Applaudissements]
la pièce que nous venons de jouer devant
vous ce soir et de armand salacrou
la mise en scène et de georges vitaly
[Applaudissements]
le décor et de jean-pierre sever
les costumes ont été choisis par jean
pierre clech
avec christiane muller
maurice pénale
daniel d'horaires
jacques vernouillet
francis là
[Applaudissements]
madeleine barbelés
bernard la valette
et judith magre 1
m
la ville
oui
avec elle
paris
la part de tous
la franchise
[Musique]